today on the matt welsh show disney
executives are now openly admitting to
their gay agenda their words not mine
another executive in a recent staff
meeting bragged about her pansexual
child we'll talk about disney's free
fall plummet into far left wokism also a
kindergarten teacher worries that the
florida bill just signed into law will
prevent him from talking to his students
about his love life
but why does he need to talk to them
about that that's the question and biden
signs the anti-lynching act thanks to
republicans who provided him this
opportunity to virtue signal jim carrey
is speaking out against will smith's
violent outburst at the oscars why is he
almost the only guy in hollywood saying
anything about it plus a republican
congressman claims that he's been
invited to drug-fueled orgies by other
members of congress in our daily
cancellation john stewart has white
guilt and he wants to tell us all about
it
we'll listen and then cancel him all of
that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're a parent then you know kids
are amazing and amazingly expensive but
with fabric protecting your family with
term life insurance is surprisingly
affordable fabric was built specifically
for parents to help you manage your
family's financial future like a
parenting pro stress free fabrics new
lower prices mean significant savings
over other providers with a great with
great policies like a million dollars in
coverage for less than a dollar a day
everything is on your scheduled fabric
because it's all online less than 10
minutes to apply and you could be
offered coverage instantly with no
health exam required no red tape it's
very simple then just personalize your
quote to fit your family's needs with
fabrics online hub it's easy to track
your family finances all in one place
get affordable life insurance set up you
can set up your college your kids
college savings plan and even establish
a rainy day savings fund all at the same
time planning for the future has never
been easier there's no risk to apply
today fabric has a 30-day money-back
guarantee and you can cancel at any time
protect your family with term life
insurance now in just 10 minutes apply
today at meet fabric dot com slash walsh
that's meet fabric dot com slash walsh
to start protecting your family today n
e e t fabric dot com welsh fabric
insurance agency policies issued by
vantis life not available in new york
and montana price is subject to
underwriting and health questions
you know i was never a very good student
of physics in high school or of any
other subject frankly but one thing i
know is that when an object starts
falling its velocity will increase the
rate of its descent will only accelerate
until it hits the ground and i've
noticed a similar thing happens with
wokeness leftism has its own
gravitational pull which ensures that
once a person organization falls into
the woke pits it will tumble towards
annihilation at ever-increasing speeds
but also there really is no ground in
this scenario leftism is more of a black
hole i guess you fall endlessly into the
darkness until you're ripped apart and
the pieces of you disintegrate and
become one with the abyss we're watching
this play out right now across our
culture disney is just one case study
but a rather instructive one now it's
true that disney has been liberal
probably since walt himself died but
they've mostly sort of been orbiting
around the black hole approaching it in
a somewhat controlled manner
but then the parental rights build in
florida came along prohibiting teachers
from talking to five-year-olds about
their sexuality uh disney facing
pressure from a small cluster of lgb to
lgbt extremists in their organization
had to make a choice
they could try to remain neutral which
would keep them in orbit around the
black hole of wokeness or they could
actively push back against the lgbt
militants which was never going to
happen but if they did it would actually
move them farther away from that black
hole or they could
cave to the radical gay factions and
come out fully in favor of teaching
seven-year-olds about transgenderism and
gender fluidity
they of course chose the latter option
which meant diving right into the hole
and now they're in the midst of an
ideological free fall
this is what lgbt activists want they
don't want you orbiting around the
perimeter they insist that you surrender
to their demands and reorganize your
whole life or your whole organization or
both
in whatever way they require
so investigative journalist chris
through foe has obtained footage
that shows just how rapid this dissent
has been
according to rufo disney recently called
an all hands meeting where multiple
executives and other high-ranking people
in the institution talked about what
disney would do
going forward to cater to the gay agenda
unless you think i'm exaggerating or
engaging in conspiracy theories with the
phrase gay agenda you should realize
that the term was actually used in the
meeting
here's executive producer latoya raveno
uh and and here she is listen
it's like i love disney's content i grew
up watching you know all of the classics
they have been a huge like informative
part of my life but at the same time
like i worked at small studios most of
my career and i'd heard you know you
hear whispers like i heard things like
oh you know they won't let you show this
at a disney show and i'm like okay so i
was a little like sus when i started and
but then
my experience was
bafflingly the opposite of what i had
heard on my little pocket of like you
know proud family disney tva um
the showrunners were super welcoming
meredith roberts and like the our
leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda and so like i i feel
like
i felt like it was i mean like maybe it
was that way in the past but i guess
like something must have happened in the
last like like they are turning it
around they're going hard
now
uh she says disney is going hard on the
gay agenda
and
no further comment needed but as bad as
that is and as disturbing is the way she
phrased it
still somehow the most troubling thing
in that video is that a grown woman is
speaking with the language and
mannerisms of a 14 year old on tick tock
but if you're wondering what the gay
agenda might look like in practice or
sound like
disney diversity and inclusion manager
vivian ware appeared later in the
meeting to give just one example of how
this gay agenda may be put into practice
listen
last summer we removed all of the um
gendered
greetings in relationship to our life
skills so we no longer say ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls
um we we've trained we provided training
for all of our our cast members and in
relationship to that so now they know
it's hello everyone or hello friends we
we are in the process of changing over
those those recorded messages and so
many of you are probably familiar when
we brought the fireworks back to the
magic kingdom we no longer say ladies
and gentlemen boys and girls we say
dreamers of all ages and so i love the
fact that it's opened up the creativity
the opportunity for our cast members to
look at that we we have our cast members
working with merchandise working with
food and beverage working with with all
of our guest spacing areas where perhaps
you know we want to create that magical
moment with our cast members with our
guests
and we don't want to just assume because
someone might be um in in our
interpretation may be presenting as
female that they may not want to be
called princess so let's think
differently about how do we really
engage with our guests in a meaningful
and inclusive way that makes it magical
and memorable for everyone
yes well we all know that nothing upsets
a little girl at disney world more than
being called princess i mean they just
hate that
good thing disney has done away with
such slurs although i should warn them
that everyone they said we're going to
say everyone instead of ladies and
gentlemen well um that's not going to be
an acceptable alternative because
everyone implies that each individual
identifies as being just a single entity
this could be quite uttering to the
self-identified days and thems in the
audience not to mention anybody with
disassociative identity disorder
everyone is not only exclusionary
transphobic but also ableist
now at another point in the meeting
disney production coordinator alan march
made an appearance where he assured the
assembled staff that his team has
created a tracker to ensure that disney
is telling a sufficient number of queer
stories listen
yeah um i've had the privilege of
working with the moon girl team for the
last two years and they've been really
open to exploring queer stories and part
of i'm on the production side uh part of
uh the work that i feel like i can put
in is
[Music]
making sure that we take place in modern
day new york so making sure that that's
like an accurate reflection of new york
so i put together like a tracker of our
background characters to make sure that
we have like the full breadth of
expression and uh we got into a very
similar conversation carrie of like oh
all of our
like gender non-conforming characters
are in the background and so it's not
just a numbers game um
of how many lgbtq plus characters you
have
we got
the further
uh the more centered a story is on a
character the more nuanced you get to
get into their story and especially with
like trans characters you can't see if
someone is trans there's not one way to
look trans and so kind of the only way
to have these like canonical trans
characters canonical asexual characters
canonical bisexual characters is to give
them stories where they can like be
their whole selves
so this is where you end up when you
free fall into woke leftism you end up
using phrases like canonical asexual
characters
although that phrase is not nearly as
disturbing as something uttered by
disney corporate president kerry burke
listen to this i'm here as a mother of
two queer children actually
um uh one transgender child um
um and one pansexual child um and and
also as a leader
um and that was the thing that really
got me because i have heard so much from
so many of my colleagues over the course
of the last couple weeks
um in open forums and through emails and
phone conversations and
um i feel a responsibility to speak um
not just for myself but for them
um to all of us we had a we had an open
forum last week at 20th where
um
again the home of really incredible
groundbreaking
lgbtqia stories over the years where
um one of our execs stood up and said
you know we only have a handful of queer
leads in our content and i went what
that can't be true and i and i and i
realized oh it actually is true
yes um
pansexual child
is what she said now please keep this in
mind if your kid is watching disney
content he is watching content produced
by people who believe in the existence
of pansexual children
now
the word pansexual of course in reality
means nothing at all it's nonsense but
according to the left in their fantasy
world a pansexual is somebody who quote
is not limited in sexual choice with
regard to biological sex gender or
gender identity
i mean the story of peter pan begins to
take on a whole new meaning
and so miss kerry burke says that
there's that her her child an actual
child
is not limited in his sexual choice by
biological sex or gender identity this
is how she speaks of children her own
children
and she has two children who are both
queer quote unquote one pansexual the
other trans how in god's name do you end
up with two children who allegedly
identify themselves with these
alternative sexual labels
well it happens because you select it
for them you hand that identity to them
the way that you might buy a child a new
jacket and tell them to put it on
a child is not going to come up with the
concept of pansexuality on his own
anymore that he's going to come up with
transgenderism
those must be given to him
we talk about things being assigned to
children well that is assigned
he has to be converted into it because
as i've argued many times the real
conversion therapy that happens in our
world today is the kind where a child is
converted into lgbt
now in a normal in an insane world the
woman in that video would be in prison
right now on charges of child abuse
instead she's a well-compensated
executive at a billion dollar multimedia
company in charge of creating
entertainment for children
she also says later in the clip that she
wants to have um half of disney's
characters
by the end of the year be lgbt or
minorities
half of them now this would seem to be
in conflict with the whole concept of a
minority
if the idea is simply representation
then why is there this push for
overrepresentation why the insistence on
making these identities more prominent
on screen than they are in real life
well
here's the important point
when these people talk about
representation
they don't mean that they want the
characters and story lines to represent
america as it currently is
they want it to represent the kind of
world and culture they wish to create
they're not representing culture they're
making it
they want to have a whole lot more quote
lgbt children which means putting a lot
more of it on the screen
they want to reshape the world which
means reshaping your child
the only question now is whether you as
a parent
are going to let them do it now let's
get to our five headlines
[Music]
according to the latest research 90
percent of employers plan to make
enhancing the employee experience a top
priority in 2022 after all a happy
workplace is key to attracting and
keeping great employees and if you need
to add more employees to your team their
ziprecruiter their matching technology
helps you find the right people for your
roles and find them fast and right now
you could try zip recruiter for free at
zippycrew.com walsh zip recruiter uses
its powerful technology to find and
match the right candidates up with your
job then it proactively presents all
these candidates to you so you can
easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply for your job which encourages
them to apply faster you're taking a
proactive approach you're not just
waiting around so that's what zip crew
is all about no wonder it's the number
one rated hiring site in the us based on
g2 ratings supercritters technology is
so effective that four out of five
employers who post on support get a
quality candidate within the first day
find the right employees for your
workplace with zip recruiter try it for
free at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com walsh that's
ziprecruiter.com
walsh zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire
well i told you yesterday about the uh
what is the woman in the the book well
we have the movie coming i also have the
book on the way what is a woman which
went on uh for pre-sale pre-sales began
yesterday you can go to amazon.com and
up and order it there go to
whatiswoman.com we do have we do own the
url for what is a woman.com and you can
go there and and uh pre-order the book
um you know i did have related to this a
little bit of a um you know a proud
husband moment yesterday when my wife uh
at a point when what is a woman was
charting on amazon at like number 22 i
think uh yeah number 22 and it was right
underneath the uh
book that will smith recently wrote
which is which has also been
surging on the charts a little bit
as you might expect and so um my my wife
tweeted this i just thought it was
fantastic she said let's get matt walsh
number one again what is a woman is
currently ranked number 22 under will
smith
nobody wants to be under will smith not
even jada
and i i just
when you can
come up with an insult that makes even
me go wow
oh boy
if i have that reaction then you know
it's pretty harsh but also
very well done
these are the kinds of things that i am
proud of you know in my marriage just
when my wife comes with a joke like that
all right i want to start with this
because we're talking about the florida
bill and um we've seen you know in many
ways this is not notable at all because
we've seen this parade of uh people
appearing on cable news teachers and and
lgbt activists from florida talking
about how horrible the bill is of course
completely misrepresenting it at the
same time
but i want to show you um this is a
kindergarten teacher who
appeared on msnbc
to talk about
the bill and the terrible consequences
that it will have for his own life and
just listen what he has to say listen
to the florida governor signing this um
into law
yeah you know it's twofold it really
hits hard um in my heart professionally
and uh personally both uh professionally
it truly makes me feel like um i am not
trusted as a professional
um i know my kindergarten standards
through and through and nowhere in our
curriculum does it have anything about
teaching sexual orientation or sexual
identity um so for them to to say that
that that's happening um it you know
it's kind of crazy um but uh we should
be able to have discussions and and
that's what we're encouraged to do in
kindergarten and then personally because
um you know my kids do have questions
they want to know who the my partner is
in pictures outside of my classroom and
i should be able to speak to that
so do you worry
that you won't even be able to talk
about your own personal home life i mean
i have a child in kindergarten right now
i know exactly
that my my child has two teachers one of
which has a daughter at home and is
single the other is married and has four
children i know everything about their
lives because my kid tells me absolutely
absolutely
you are 100 correct um
that's what we do as educators we build
relationships with our kids and in order
to build relationships you talk about
your home life you talk about what you
do on the weekends that's building
community i it scares me
to death that i am not going to be able
to have these conversations with my
children because they're going to ask me
what i did on the weekend i don't want
to have to hide that my partner and i
went paddleboarding this weekend
it scares him to death that he can't
tell
his children listen to the phrasing
there
that um
that he went paddle boarding over the
weekend he's scared to death that he
can't talk about his paddle boarding
trip with the kindergartners so now it's
the it's the don't say paddleboard bill
apparently
he wants to be able to share his life
with his kids now now listen
of course in truth there is actually
nothing in the bill whatsoever that
would prevent that dude
from telling
his children who are not his children
their students they may be
kindergartners but that's of course how
he sees it very revealing that's how
these teachers see it they think it's
their children but my children
but there's nothing actually in the bill
that would prevent him from talking
about his paddleboard trip
or even saying hey kids i went on a
paddle board porting trip uh with with
uh with my gay partner i'm a gay man who
went on a paddle boarding trip
he according to the bill he can still
say that
i don't think he should but there's
actually nothing in the bill at all that
would stop that from happening
it's not in there
but it does raise the question of why
do you need to share this information
with the kids anyway
like the kids are going to ask what you
did over the weekend
really they are they really going to ask
you that
i guess i guess i was a a unusually
selfish child and every other
kid in my class when i was in elementary
school also was unusually selfish
because i
nobody ever asked the teacher that we
didn't sit down on monday and say so uh
mrs smith what did you do over the
weekend who's who is having that
conversation with it do you think
kindergartners little five-year-olds are
coming in says hey say uh have a great
weekend how'd it go
kids aren't asking you that they don't
care about that
and even if they did
ask you that like it's it's not a whole
long conversation you need to have
i mean even if there was a law saying
that uh you can't talk about your gay
relationships which again that's not
actually what the law says but even if
there was you could still say i went
paddle boarding over the weekend there's
nothing stopping you from saying that
do you need to get into specifics about
your relationship
i'm sorry i don't believe
that quote unquote his children are
asking him all about his private life
i've never heard of such a thing kids
don't care about that
but even if they do
why do you need to talk about this
when i went to school
i didn't know anything
about the private lives of any of my
teachers
i think as i've said before i really
thought for much of my
my younger years in school
i thought that they all like lived in
the school i thought they were kept in a
crypt or something in the basement and
then just wheeled out to teach us the
abcs and then sent back into their into
their lair or whatever that's what i
figured i i didn't even i didn't think
about their private lives at all i
assume they didn't have them because
they were just my teachers
they didn't sit down to talk about their
marital problems or anything like that
um why do you need to talk about it
well here's the answer
it's um
for these these teachers taking the lgbt
stuff
putting it all the way to the side
for a lot of these teachers now
that what they're do it's it's
everything is self-focused
as we always talk about with leftism
everything comes back to the self
the entire worldview is turned in on
itself and it's nothing but just a it's
a it's a fun house
you know hall of mirrors
and everything just reflects back to
them so teaching
um certainly for for the mentality of a
leftist teaching is not about
the kids it's not about
relaying information on whatever subject
you're teaching it's about you
and so it's unthinkable that you would
not be able to put yourself into it and
talk about yourself that's the main
thing they want to talk about
you think that you're sending your kids
to school to learn the abcs in the one
two threes but really as far as the
teachers are concerned you're learning
you're sending them to school to learn
about the teachers
and as they're talking about themselves
incessantly maybe they'll throw in
um a little bit of two plus two here and
there
it is unthinkable to them
that maybe it's not about you
that weirdo that we just saw like it's
who it's not about you
no one is sending their kid to
kindergarten to learn about you
nobody cares about you the parents don't
care the kids it's not about you that's
not why they're there this is not story
time with mr whoever
all about his life
just keep yourself out of it keep
personal life out of it
even though there's no law stopping you
from talking about your personal life
maybe there should be
you know what maybe that's maybe that
should be the consequence
all of these idiots claiming that this
law has been passed stopping them from
talking about their personal lives if i
was in charge the consequence would be
you know what that law doesn't exist but
now we're going to make one
because that apparently is the law you
want to argue again so here i'll give
you something to cry about
how about a law for all teachers just
you're not allowed to talk about your
personal lives at all all you're allowed
to talk about is the subject and that's
it
doesn't matter what's going on your
personal life can't talk about it talk
about the subject
if that's unthinkable to you if that's
some horrifying
possibility uh then go do something else
with your life
if you cannot separate your damned ego
from your job as a teacher then please
go do something else we don't need you
all right
let's move on to uh
joe biden yesterday signed the
anti-lynching act and uh before we talk
a little bit more about this
anti-lynching lack let's
let's listen to joe biden who you know
he's he's uh
had just one bad day after another
politically and it's been his entire
tenure has been a succession of bad days
where
it only seems somehow to get worse and
worse and you think it couldn't possibly
get worse the next day it is worse um so
he was very excited to have
um a crowd-pleasing moment like this
where he could get up and bravely take a
stand against
lynching
and let's listen to that a little bit
it was over a hundred years ago in 1900
a north carolina representative george
henry white the son of a slave the only
black lawmaker in congress at the time
who first introduced legislation to make
lynching a federal crime hundreds
hundreds of similar bills have failed to
pass
over the years
several federal hate crime laws were
enacted including one i signed last year
to combat covet 19 hate crimes but no
federal law
no federal law expressly prohibited
lynching none
until today
how brave how no first of all i know
that i'm not i'm the last guy to make
fun of anybody for their pronunciations
but at the same time he did say hundreds
hundreds hundreds of laws have not
passed
um he says no federal law has expressly
forbid lynching
that's technically true
because of the word expressly
but
there are federal laws that do in fact
prohibit lynching even if it's not
expressly
doesn't need to be expressly
stated because we do have a we have a
federal hate crime laws
where if you commit a violent act
against someone
um for racist reasons
that's a federal hate crime it doesn't
it doesn't it doesn't
whatever the violent act is
so yeah as it stands right now until
this lynching law came along maybe it
didn't specify every possible violent
act you could pot you could commit if
you commit a violent racist act of
punching someone if you stab them if you
shoot them if you drown them like do we
do we need to
specify each individual thing that you
might do
no it's it's
racist violence is already a federal
hate crime and lynching very much falls
under that umbrella like it's it's in
that category 100 so
if prior to this law you had gone and
lynched somebody you would be going to
prison forever as a murderer and you
would also be hit with hate crime
charges um provided that this was done
you know is racially motivated
so that was already the case
already the case
um
but it it it didn't really come up
because you might think well uh by
when's the last time someone uh you say
that somebody could be prosecuted as a
for federal hate crimes in the past or
for committing a lynching but when's the
last time that happened well it's been a
really long time because it's been a
really long time since anyone has
lynched anybody else
it's been decades and decades
and the last the most recent occasion i
think was in the early 80s if i remember
correctly i looked this up in the past
and even that was an isolated incident
that was uh
shocking because it had been decades and
decades before it happened before that
so in the last like 50 years how many
people have been lynched um
a few and
none in the last 30 or 40
doesn't make it okay obviously doesn't
mean that because it hasn't happened it
should be legal but the good thing is it
wasn't
it was already a crime on every level
it's like on every level of government
it was already a crime
now it's just a crime a second time
and uh but that will make no effective
difference whatsoever but here's you
know i've i've made this point about
this anti-lynching bill and this
totally like
cynical
you want to talk about
cynicism
i i think there could be no better
example of it than this
making this big show of of
uh
you know prohibiting a crime that was
already prohibited and that nobody is
committing anyway
so a cynical
virtue signaling ploy
and yeah we're used to that from the
left we're used to that from the
democrats obviously joe biden is going
to take any
thing like this that he can get um
any softballs that you lob to him he's
gonna he's gonna go ahead and take him
and he'll still you know he'll still
whiff on a lot of the softballs but yeah
he'll appreciate
but why did the republicans go along
with this
this only happened
because almost every republican in
congress
in both the house and the senate with
the exception of three or four
went along with this
even though they all knew that this was
totally absurd and the only reason this
is being done is to give joe biden a
chance to virtue signal and every
republican almost every republican
congressman congress went along
with this in order in order to give joe
biden a chance to purchasing
and not only virtue signal but cynically
exploit
racial tensions actual hate crimes i
mean you know treating
actual lynching which never occurs
anymore but it turns into this political
pawn
and republicans went along with it
and why did they go along with it
well because as i've been reminded when
i've complained about this oh well well
if they didn't they would have been
called racist
oh not that oh certainly i mean yeah
well go go along with whatever the left
wants so uh because otherwise they'll
call you racist yeah the only problem is
that
even if you do go along with them they
still call you races is there any
democrat have you heard a single
democrat giving props to republicans and
saying hey you know what maybe these
guys aren't as bad as i thought they're
not actually racist they they're against
lynching two look they signed the bill
or they they voted for the bill
is any democrat doing that
no you're still a racist nazi in their
minds doesn't it makes no difference
vote for the bill or don't you're you're
a racist either way
so why go along with it
you know a better approach
would be for every republican to refuse
to go along and then to explain why
to just explain it as i've explained it
it's not hard to do
you know with republicans there's
so much of their story
can be explained by their own cowardice
of course and their own stupidity but
also
their belief
that
that we are stupid
that most of us are stupid
and yeah there are plenty of stupid
people out there
but i think the american people in
general are capable of understanding
like basic concepts so um
you could just explain hey listen
it won't take it takes like 30 seconds
to say hey we're not signing this bill
uh this is a cynical ploy on their part
lynching is already illegal it's already
a federal hate crime too and and so
that's why we're not signing we're not
going along with this in fact we're we
find it outrageous that they're they're
doing this in the first place
is that so hard to say
but of course republicans
always always eagerly you know sort of
digging dirt on their own graves
all right
we move now to uh
the slap gate some updates on that first
of all i just thought this is
interesting interesting from the daily
star you know there are people who are
not giving up on this uh idea that the
whole thing was staged and so the daily
star has this will smith's brutal smack
of chris rock at the 2022 oscar ceremony
was a choreographed hollywood display
one body language expert says celebrity
psychic and body language expert imbal
honingman has explained that the
incident comes off as a
backslapping display which saw the two
men appear dignified and leisurely at
least on the surface dignified dignified
and leisurely
and i only saw this because people were
sharing as i see you see it's a it's all
this was all a stunt it's all a
conspiracy
i am glad that this woman is a body
language expert and psychic
because those two things are truly the
same i mean they're both an absolute
scam but these body language acts but
well you see when he uh he moved he
twitched his finger in a certain way
which means that he's thinking about
this like shut up
do you i i've already addressed this but
somehow i mean of all of all the
dumb conspiracy theories this one
somehow annoys me the most just because
it is so stupid and you have to have
absolutely no understanding of human
nature and especially of what makes a
celebrity sort of tick to to go to think
that this was a
stage pl you think
that we've talked about how will smith
would never as serious as these people
take themselves
he would never go along with something
that's going to overshadow his own
oscars win
and cause career damage to him
he would
for the sake of a stunt that some
producer at the oscars pitched to him
but so that's clear but chris rock you
think chris rock is gonna volunteer to
be slapped in the face
on television a moment that will will
live
uh hollywood infamy that like that
anytime you think of chris rock for the
rest of your life anytime his name comes
up forever
that is going to be front and center is
getting slapped in the face
did chris rock agreed to that he agreed
that you know what i want my whole
legacy to be getting slapped in the face
for the sake of this oscars bit um
because i that's how much i care about
oscar's ratings i'm gonna i'm gonna
throw my whole career on the burn pile
and um
be be totally disgraced in front of the
entire world so that the oscars get
better ratings
come on guys just stop with that okay
no no
nobody would do that especially not a
celebrity at a at the oscars
these are not people known for
self-deprecation
especially not self-deprecation to that
extent absurd
uh but you know after all this happened
um
it it
there's a the sort of the silence is
deafening because
there were a lot of celebrities there
who watched this all happen and very few
of them are speaking out um the one guy
we've heard is jim carrey he was on cbs
yesterday let's listen to a little bit
of this and him reacting to the uh to
the slap
what did you think as you watched it
unfold and then what happened after
i was sickened i was sickened by the
standing ovation
i felt like hollywood is just spineless
on mass
and uh it just
it really felt like oh this is a really
clear indication that we're not the cool
club anymore there was some question
today about if anyone else had walked
from the audience and done that they
would have been escorted out by security
or maybe even arrested the police asked
ask chris
to file charges
they asked chris do you want to file
charges and chris apparently said no he
did not
he doesn't want the hassle i i'd i'd
for announced this morning that i was
suing will for 200 million dollars
because that video is going to be there
forever it's going to be ubiquitous
you know that insult is
going to last a very long time if you
want to yell from the audience and
disapprove or show a disapproval or say
something on twitter or whatever you you
know you do not have the right to to
walk up on stage and smack somebody in
the face because they said words
yeah i mean everything you said of
course is completely reasonable and by
the way as i'm listening to this i'm
thinking about the tragedy of twitter
because
twitter kind of gives you an insight
into people's mindsets um and who they
they really are and
that view is often quite
discouraging um for a lot of people so
jim carrey for example
you know if not for twitter
all i would know about him is the the
movies i've seen him in and then like an
interview like that where he comes off
as a really reasonable guy
and i would think well okay he's just a
reasonable sane
you know dignified guy it seems like
um
but then but then he's on twitter all
the time especially during during
trump's tenure like ranting about trump
he's got all he making all these obscene
paintings of trump and posting them just
coming off like a total
fruitcake uh that if not for twitter we
wouldn't know about that side of him at
all there are so many people in the
public light that it's it's like that's
not for twitter there's this whole
ugly side of them that if not for that
we wouldn't even know it existed and our
impression of this person would be
completely different
um
anyway but what he said there
of course right
it does it shouldn't take courage to
stand up and say that like yeah you
can't get up from your seat in the
middle of
an awards ceremony and slap a comedian
in the face because he made a joke you
didn't like
but as
basic as that concept is
just to show you the cowardice in
hollywood no one else is saying it
i think there were a few celebrities who
originally tweeted about it and said
that they disapproved and a lot of them
deleted it afterwards
and when it comes to the a-listers as
far as i know
if we can call jim carrey and a-lister
still he's the only one who's come out
and say yeah you know what i am opposed
to
getting up at an award ceremony and
slapping a comedian because he made a
joke i didn't like i'm opposed to that
count me in the anti column for that one
just
suffocating overwhelming cowardice
in hollywood
and after all the virtue signaling they
did prior to this
you know uh we're standing for ukraine
we're standing for the rights of uh for
human rights and all this kind of stuff
and
and then they watch a violent incident
in their own midst
and they all they all shrink away
they all wilt like little flowers
because when it's something happening
yeah they could stand there and say f
you putin
because you're in hollywood
and that's happening thousands of miles
away and it's really easy to say
but when it's in your own when it's
happening right next to you you can't
say anything because you're too afraid
um
all right let's move
we do it i want to make sure we have
time for this representative madison
cawthorns a republican
he made a claim in a podcast interview
that has provoked
mostly mockery from both
left and right but
it's a pretty notable claim that he made
so i think it's worth listening to let's
do that
kevin spacey
and
i forget who else uh was in it um but a
really well done show very well done
very well done but it was so dirty and
it was about this uh congressman
who was kevin spacey who was i think it
was minority or majority whip yep what
was it yeah and so anyway very very
powerful guy
and it was just kind of like his secret
life of all this corruption and power
and money and perversion and it was just
dirty how
much in your opinion because you're
you've been behind the veil is this
a
fictitious
show
or is this more closer to like a
documentary is it that bad so
i heard a former president that we had
in the 90s was asked the question about
this
and he gave an answer that i thought was
so true and he said the only thing
that's not accurate in that show is that
you could never get a piece of
legislation about uh about education
past that quickly
and everything else is good aside from
that i mean the sexual perversion that
goes on washing out i mean it being kind
of a young guy in washington with the
average age of probably 60 or 70.
and i look at all these people a lot of
them that i you know i've looked up to
through my life i've always paid
attention to politics guys that you know
then all of a sudden you get invited to
like well hey we're going to have kind
of a
sexual get-together at one of our homes
you should come and i'm like
what did you just ask me to come to yeah
and then you realize they're asking you
to come to an orgy yeah uh or the fact
that you know there's some of the people
that are leading on the movement to try
and remove you know addiction in our
country and then you watch them do a
keyboard cocaine right in front of you
how old is
madison call he
he looks like he's 17 how old is he
actually
um but that's not really the point he
says
first of all he says that uh house of
cards was a really well done show which
that we know is an absolute false
narrative that's not as a terrible show
is horrible
um
and then and then he says that he's been
invited to orgies in congress
and you you try
not to even and then and then your mind
starts like
immediately you start thinking about who
we have in congress and uh it's it's
quite disturbing and horrifying
and just just stop yourself from
vomiting you you you your mind has to
has to cut it off there um like who
exactly is involved in these origins i i
i don't want to know
now he says that he's been invited
to
a a sexual get together and i i will
admit now i've never
been in this environment before
so i don't know but i i'm
i'm skeptical
that if you were going to be invited to
an orgy somebody would say to you uh
would you like to come to a sexual get
together is that is that really how it
would be phrased
you might as well just say orgy at that
point say hey i'm going to send you an
rsvp on the hey i set you an invitation
to that orgy did you i didn't get the
rcp yet this is anything oh my email
okay i'll check is that how it goes is
it that direct
a sexual get together
or maybe it's just hey would you we're
having to get together in my house what
kind of get together it's a sexual one
yeah sexual a little bit of drugs too
i don't know i didn't think that the
that it would necessarily go that way or
that that's how they would talk about it
um
but at the same time so
the fact that he phrased it this way and
tied it to house of cards as being used
to dismiss the entire claim
but there's no doubt number one
as he says plenty of sexual perversion
in congress we we certainly know that
i mean there were members of congress
one in particular who comes to mind
who is having like threesomes with her
own staff members so that sort of thing
definitely happens
now whether katie hill invited people by
saying would you like to come to a
sexual get together
at my house this evening
you know that's that's sort of semantics
but there's no question that the sexual
perversion is there these are all a
bunch of degenerates no doubt about that
and also it's interesting i saw someone
make this point on twitter
that the people who are laughing
hysterically
at the claim that members of congress
would engage in this kind of activity
these are the exact people
who took as fact right away and had no
skepticism
about the claim that brett kavanaugh was
the ringleader of some sort of
gang of of uh of serial rapists and that
he would go to rape parties
that to them was totally credible they
they thought that was
the fact that some of these claims were
being filtered through
michael avenatti no problem to them
and yet this claim is somehow
beyond the pale doesn't make a lot of
sense to me let's move now to the
comment sections
[Music]
a few comments here about the daily
cancellation yesterday we talked about
the
how we're
pathologizing grief now grief is now a
medical disorder a mental disorder
according to pharmaceutical industries
psychiatric industry who
coincidentally
stand to make billions of dollars in
profits additional profits by
medicalizing uh yet another aspect of
the human condition so some people are
reacting to that debbie says my father
died five years ago my mom 12 months ago
i cry when i think of them both no way
i'm taking drugs to get over it
b barrett says grief is always going to
be a part of us we don't get over it we
learn to perform our day-to-day activity
while carrying it
one says it's been over two decades and
i still feel the grief
processing the feelings takes longer and
becomes more difficult to live with
when we avoid feeling it fully and
sorting through all the negative
emotions
and this is got a lot of comments like
that
um from people who've
experienced real loss in their life
spouses children parents that sort of
thing
and um
what everyone
the consensus agreement seems to be that
you don't really you never get over it
in the sense of you just go back to
normal like the person never existed you
wouldn't want to get over it in that way
you just you learn to live with it you
carry with you but you're always going
to be sad i mean god forbid you lose a
child there's never going to be a time
50 years later there's not gonna be a
time where when it doesn't make you
profoundly
deeply
uh devastatingly sad to think about
and you just carry but you carry it with
you and you and you continue living
so there are ways the problem though is
that
um
well there are many problems but one of
them
is that we've decided the only way to
help people now is through
drugs
and so
if you come out against using drugs to
solve a problem
then automatically what you're saying in
the minds of a lot of people is that you
don't want to help at all you don't
think these people should be helped
but no that's not the case
there are many ways to help someone in
grief now you can't take it away you
can't take their grief away because you
can't
take away the cause of the grief which
is the absence of this person that they
loved
but you can help them to live with it
and you do that through counseling
support groups being there for them i
mean just like these human
interactions like this this is what is
causing the pain is the loss of a human
connection someone that they cared about
deeply and so if you're going to help
them through it what they need is a
human connection not a damn drug
how is this any different by the way
how's this any different like
you might as well just prescribe to
someone in grief that they go home and
drink a bottle of whiskey
it's the same thing and i i can
understand if i lost someone really
close to me i'm sure i'd be very tempted
to respond to it in that way but
that's just you're trying to numb the
pain which is a human instinct it's
understandable
that's all it is you put it in the form
of a drug and you you make a fancy
pharmaceutical commercial for it
and you have pfizer somebody selling it
and all of a sudden it's a different
concept no it's not
you know a pill is no more a medicine
for grief or despair than a bottle of
alcohol is
they both effectively do the same thing
which is to numb you to it
but they don't solve it or make it go
away
um
octarian war criminal says we have
officially found matt's worst shirt
sweet daddy walsh truly has disappointed
us today
how dare you says i would condone will
smith's slapping mat for wearing that
shirt
and then i guess i don't have to keep
reading these comments
a lot of people this this seemed to be
another consensus agreement is that the
shirt i wore yesterday i thought it was
a nice shirt but the shirt was very
disturbing to a lot of people i guess
because maybe it kind of blended in with
my with my skin tone
it was not my intention
to wear a nude colored shirt but i guess
that's how it came off
on so when you first clicked on the
episode you saw me and it looked like i
was just wearing no clothes at all but
you know what
and a lot of people are recoiling horror
at that thought but but that that number
one is body shaming to me
so what if i was doing the show without
any clothes on you know you can't
complain about that without body shaming
i thought it was a great shirt uh savvy
moon says matt that shirt you're wearing
today is very nice okay good i guess we
got one
me and this one person we agree on the
shirt and you know what happens now
i mean you know what happens you
complain about a shirt that i wore you
say it was ugly it's disturbing it's
giving you nightmares what does that
mean it just means i'm gonna wear it a
lot more now
you've done this to yourself well the
left has infiltrated every facet of the
entertainment industry including sports
athletes kneel out of worship to the
prevailing woke ideology and virtue
signal
and they are doing all these things of
course with some exceptions like nba
star jonathan isaac who despite facing
heavy criticism from the media for his
views on social issues and vaccines over
the past few years stood strong while
everybody else was on their knees which
is why i'm extremely excited to announce
that he's decided to write a book with a
daily wire called why i stand jonathan's
book will be about the rise of his
basketball career his journey into faith
and his strength to stand alone in the
face of immense pressure the book is
available for pre-order now at amazon so
go reserve your copy today now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so it's with great pleasure today that i
canceled jon stewart now jon stewart
actually has a show which streams on
apple tv in which generates enthusiasm
and public interest about on the level
with a wnba game
if you're like the average person you
probably didn't even know that the show
existed the last you heard from stewart
was probably several months ago when he
went viral for criticizing some aspects
of the mainstream covet narrative it was
last year and he earned many high fives
and back slaps from the right for this
moment of lucidity
oh that jon stewart
conservative said he's not he's not woke
like other liberals he's one of the good
ones you know this is a familiar process
someone on the left says something
mildly sane and then is immediately
valorized by the right as a champion of
truth and common sense he's baptized
usually against his will as an honorary
conservative even as 99.9 percent of his
worldview still remains firmly planted
on the left end of the political
spectrum
the next step in the process is
inevitable the newly christened
conservative hero proceeds shortly after
this fleeting episode of rationality
to go back to far left talking points
and then he is once again demonized by
the same conservatives who two seconds
before we're ready to canonize him
around and around we go nothing ever
changes
on that note here is jon stewart on his
apple tv show talking to his viewers
about or rather to his viewer
about the problem with white people
listen
for however sincerely we want to reckon
and listen
the truth is america has always
prioritized white comfort over black
survival black people have had to fight
so hard for equality
that they've been irreparably set back
in the pursuit of equity
and any real attempt to uh rep rep
repair
a ton of
that damage
reparation
sets off white peoples they're coming
for our alarm which we would know
ourselves
had we actually been listening
my feeling is white people
have a very very serious
problem
and they should start thinking
about what they can do about it
take me out of it
understood
so what you can't see in that video
because it's just out of frame is ibrmx
kendi standing there with a gun pointed
right at jon stewart at least i assume
that's what's happening because the
whole thing has the looks sound and feel
of one of those taliban hostage videos
only it's worse than that because the
taliban to my knowledge doesn't usually
castrate the hostage before filming the
video
stuart on the other hand sits there like
a docile gelding head bowed meekly
whispering understood
after a black woman declares that
everything is the fault of white people
later in the episode stewart uh brought
on a panel of fellow self-hating whites
to talk about uh some more about how
awful white people are
there was one man involved in the
conversation andrew sullivan who had the
gumption to suggest that perhaps white
people are not necessarily spawns of
satan and that maybe in fact there might
even be some good things about america
in american history and white people
these outrageous claims were dutifully
shouted down by stewart and the other
panelists listen to that
you're not living on the same [ __ ]
planet we are
honestly
i really don't think you are if you are
not living i think you are not living in
the planet most americans are which is
why this kind of extremism
right this anti-white extremism yes is
losing
popular support is
creating a backlash is going to elect
republicans and undo a lot of the good
you think you're doing this is what
happens when you don't talk about it
this is what happens when white people
don't talk about it is you have
racist dog whistle tropes like this that
actually perpetuate and perpetuate and
perfect
so i am i i and i did not come on this
on this show to sit here and argue with
another white man that's one of the
reasons that we don't even engage with
white men at race to dinner
you know because quite honestly if white
men were going to do something about
racism you had 400 years you coulda done
[Applause]
oh she's not going to engage with white
men
she went on a white man's show
to sit on a panel with white men
but she doesn't want to talk to white
men
she hates white men she despises them
doesn't even think that they should be
able to speak and she feels comfortable
vocalizing all of this bigotry because
she expects that she'll be applauded for
it and she was but remember
all of our systems are racist against
black people even though the only group
of people you can actually be openly
racist against are white people
especially white men makes total sense
if you're brain damaged or have single
digit iq which is precisely the
demographic that critical race theory
appeals to the most
now the angry portly woman there with
the bad haircut says that white men
should have already done something about
racism we have 400 years she says
to which you might point out that it was
largely white men who abolished slavery
um white men didn't invent slavery but
they did abolish it white men in fact
are responsible for many of the best
things about our civilization that's
just a fact white men have been busy you
know
inventing modern science and building
skyscrapers and fighting and dying in
our wars and defeating the nazis
creating modern medicine inventing cars
electricity space travel antibiotics
writing the greatest novels and plays
and poems in history that's what white
men have been up to
but they're not worthy of even speaking
to the bitter cat lady on the jon
stewart panel she turns up her nose at
the whole group be gone she says
well okay maybe we'll go but you better
hope we don't take all our stuff with us
on the way out the door because you're
not gonna be left with much if we do
but hold on a second she said that uh
white men had 400 years to do something
about racism
why 400 years specifically i mean what
about and what about everybody else on
earth
what was everyone else doing about
racism
who exactly was fighting against racism
400 years ago
well she says 400 years ago because
she's a mindless disciple of the 1619
project and she believes that racism was
invented around that time and that it
was white people who invented it and
only white people who ever engaged in it
in reality of course racism has existed
in the human species everywhere on earth
in every population everywhere since the
dawn of civilization
racism is just one form of tribalism
it's a form of tribalism that still
exists in the world today in fact and
can be found in much more virulent and
violent forms in the parts of the world
where white people are least present
it's not just that there is racial and
ethnic tribalism in africa and asia too
it's that there's a whole hell of a lot
more of it in those regions of the world
and it comes in a far more brutal
package
now going back in history i asked
earlier
who exactly was fighting against racism
400 years ago i'm not claiming that
white men were but and they weren't but
but who was
well the answer is nobody
not a soul on earth back in those days
the idea that all people should be
treated equally regardless of how they
look or where they're from is an idea
that simply did not exist
anywhere in the world 400 years ago
that idea had to be thought of and
codified into law and guess who thought
of it
that's right white men
now granted the white men who came up
with the concept did not actually apply
it consistently because when it came
down to it they shared the flaws that
were ubiquitous in almost all human
beings on earth at that time
but they certainly set the stage for
racial equality under the law
they put the framework in place
i'd say that's a pretty significant
achievement
even if it doesn't impress the panelist
on jon stewart's show or john stewart
himself
but who really cares because anyway
jon stewart is today cancelled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
hey there this is john bickley daily
wire editor-in-chief and co-host of
morning wire on today's episode the u.s
warns of another major offensive by
russia as peace talks with ukraine
continue new data shows that
alcohol-related deaths spiked under
covet and president biden releases his
controversial budget
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire